our next series is a series on methadone
deaths by the Seattle Times some time
ago some doctors approached reporters at
the Seattle Times and told them there
were too many people dying of methadone
overdose the result of that conversation
was a three-part series that exposed how
more than 2,000 people in Washington
State fatally overdose and the
painkiller methadone accidental deaths
resulting from overdosing on
prescription painkillers is not a new
issue last year the Center for Disease
Control labeled these deaths and
epidemic with a death toll more than
tripling in the past 20 years but
Michael barons and Ken Armstrong found
something new and unique about the
deaths in their state most of the
methadone deaths they found were of poor
people in the past eight years
Washington had steered to methadone
those with state subsidized health care
such as Medicaid patients injured
workers and state employees this is
because methadone is cheap low-income
patients were often given no other
choice many of them were not told the
drug lick that the drug lingers in the
bloodstream for days potentially build
into toxic levels it can also paralyze
the respiratory muscles so patients
could just stop breathing and die for
sure the drugs saved the state money but
poor patients paid for those savings
with their lives the Seattle Times team
got the data on more than 2,000 people
who had died of methadone overdose then
they located the fatalities addresses on
a map each red dot on that map
represents a methadone death the team
found it in the lowest income
neighborhoods the death rate was three
times higher than in affluent areas the
richer parts like Mercer Island where
folks like Bill Gates live have no
methadone deaths at all Washington's
death rate from methadone ranks among
the country's highest yet state
officials had done little to address the
issue instead they passed a law that
impose restrictions and doctors who can
only prescribe painkillers after certain
dosage levels as a result hon
maybe thousands of people of patients
were turned away by doctors and denied
pain medicine meanwhile methadone
prescriptions were on the rise given by
clinics like the one featured in this
report where six patients had fatally
overdosed pharmacies medical providers
patients the country sheriff even the
drug enforcement authority had fired
more than 100 complaints about this
clinic yet state regulators didn't take
any action the impact of the series was
immediate and dramatic within days the
state issued an emergency public health
advisory warning of the unique risk of
methadone as a painter on within weeks
the state also declared methadone no
longer the preferred drug for chronic
pain management and for the first time
the state the state warned patients that
methadone should only be used as a last
resort Michael Barons I'm a big fan of
the series which I first read last year
this issue has brought your attention by
medical professionals concerned about
the accidental deaths from methadone
overdose how did you go about reporting
it did you have some idea in the
beginning what the story would
ultimately be focusing on well let me go
off the reservations for a second and
just say to the crowd thanks for showing
up tonight when I was at a house state
back in 1979 there was this guy named
Frank Reynolds I believe a dignitary
from the networks and he was giving a
speech and I happened to wonder into a
hall like this one and I'm sitting in
the back of the room and I was in a
pre-law kind of major and I listened to
this guy he was broadcast he's talking
about journalism and it so inspired me
that I switched my major the next day
and and went into journalism and you
know it's just sitting in a crowd like
this thing you know there's something
electrifying about this and so what I
wanted to say very quickly before I get
to the question is thanks you know for
being here to journalism is great don't
let anyone tell you it isn't and
investigative reporting is alive and you
can't make money out of believe it or
not i think we all you know make a
little bit of money here and and so
there yeah i just wanna say you know it
there there is nothing like this
profession and
and I'm here because you know I love
what I do so let me get to the question
how did how do I know and how to distort
come to me and I brought the copy of the
original email with me I'll just read
you the first paragraph and I'll tell
you this is the challenge with
investigative reporting but here's
here's the story tip it came as an email
from a doctor in Washington the core
story is that stage agencies are allowed
to perform therapeutic substitutions
within any drug class such as long
acting opioids and generate preferred
drugless I you pick a cheap drug based
on non-transparent rebates with Pharma
song as the state pharmacy and
therapeutics committee under health care
authority determines there is no
evidence and in drug within that classes
any riskier I don't know about you but I
screams Pulitzer doesn't it I mean you
know you read that and say wow this is
it this is my career no you know it was
the most incomprehensible unbelievably
dense email and and it was really tough
to get through and it was it went for
about three pages you know and it's you
get these kind of emails all the time
and I'm sure you know you look at here's
another guy raining about the government
or whatever but you know you read it and
so does the secret to to my approach is
I have a checklist that i use for
determining what makes a story I put my
webpage up there on the board watchdog
reporter calm my handouts are on there
so there's a handout with this checklist
it's a 10 point checklist it's nothing
magical it's just common sense
information but what I look for most of
on what I looked for when I read this
email is this something new is there
something at whist that I can report on
here most importantly is this something
that I can quantify and what this doctor
said is that there are deaths linked to
methadone that that no one wants to
acknowledge and in the real course
simple issue you know what is the reform
you know why am I doing this story is
there potential reform and when I saw in
his email is the state is giving out a
drug and they're not warning people
about how risky it is and people are
unnecessarily dying because they're
unaware of the risk you know very simple
concept at its core complex story kind
of a niche in the healthcare system but
very simple and here's what my mission
is my mission is to inform the public
about the risks of this drug when I
got the state of Washington say it's not
risky it's just as safe as any other
drug great so how did you get the
evidence to to bolster that story to
prove that story what what did you do
next my first step in these projects as
I said on this checklist the most
important criteria for me is
quantification so when I read a story
the thing that drives me crazy when to
reinvestigate stories there are about a
hundred deaths linked to this or there
there are estimated to be one hundred
and you know dust linked us what I'd
like to do is come and say there were 97
deaths linked to this I like the
precision you know the precision
journalism so what I look for is a way
to quantify so in the state of
Washington we're fortunate because death
certificates are public records and so
we obtained the database of every death
for ten years in the state of Washington
is approximately 40,000 plus dust a year
and with each computer entry I got
probably 30 40 pieces of information
about every death what was the primary
cause of death was accidental or
intentional was there a crime involved
what we're drumming up there was drugs
if it was an overdose death it would
tell me what the primary drug was an
abaya show me any secondary or third
drugs so by putting them into a database
I was able to look at every person who
had methadone in their body at the time
of death and whether methadone was the
sole drug in their body or whether there
were other drugs such as you know
benzodiazepines which are often common
for depression are those kinds of other
issues so we were able to very quickly
categorize that the population of desk
then when did you have the idea to map
those deaths to put those that you know
to mark the addresses of those who had
died which was you know the map mouri
the man when do we have the idea for
mapping it was right away very from the
beginning let's show people where the
desks are and part of the reasoning for
us and start off is just a simple dot
map with with not the layer of income
which came later as we started learning
more about this but the visually I just
like the every project I do I just like
to show people where is it at and what I
like to do for the reader is this isn't
some esoteric topic that affects you
know other people here's someone
probably in your neighborhood you know
here's someone in your zip code and that
was the first purpose of the dot map was
to say here's here's where the people
are this is real you know these are our
neighbors and these are people make a
letter to come and show us
okay so this is the dot map and and what
we did is made it interactive so that
you got beyond just the one surface
level here's where they at and we tried
to show here's here's the the
differentiation and income and this came
towards the end of the project is we
realized that the state program that
picks which drugs people have to take
our is a state program that primarily
catters caters to Medicaid recipients
and so we started wondering why I wonder
if most of the deaths that are Medicaid
desk even though any doctor can
subscribe methadone if they have a
choice is method on the first choice or
not and so when we started mapping this
we started color coding the areas and
basically the darker areas are the
wealthy areas in state of Washington and
the lighter areas of the low-income and
so let's take a look here here's Mercer
Island so if you click on the island you
can see here we have a pop-up that shows
that this is a 1000 to 185 thousand
dollar medium income based on census
data and as you can see there's not a
single dot and mercer island but you go
over here where there's a lot of dots
and you'll see that this is zero to
forty five thousand dollar census tract
and then when you click on the
individual dots you were able to see
what year this person died and we gave
just some general information and i can
explain that later if you want but the
reason why we didn't give more is
because we didn't want to unnecessarily
embarrass specific families we're even
worried about how far we allow people to
drill down on the map because with
today's mapping you can actually drill
down to the house you know particularly
with satellite imaging and we were
scared that this would cause harm and
unnecessary hurt the family so we only
allow people to drill so far down but
with the slider here you could go really
minut if you wanted to or you could pull
back far away and see the masa dots and
our purpose was to show people you know
we're not making this up this isn't some
manufactured media issue you know that
we're trying to make this is this is
very real and when you have 2,700 deaths
in the state of Washington link to this
drug and so we allow people and gave
them the power you know to go into their
specific neighborhoods
yeah well it's hard to find you know
that if as you drill down into the
specific neighborhood you start seeing
the differential where there are you
know obviously people died in the
wealthier areas as well but the majority
of those deaths were in the low income
areas and it becomes very stark as you
know the area and you start looking well
did you find that with this database
people engage with the story in a
different way in a way they would not
have done if it was purely a text story
I think the power of the data and why we
invest so much in it is it allows people
to look for themself and see the proof
for themselves you know in other words
don't just look at the story but look at
the data it also plays a dual role with
telling the state you know we know what
we're doing here and it helps when
you're doing your final interviews you
know instead of saying you know we have
people tell us there's methadone
destined that there's a bunch of
unnecessary deaths out there in a state
of Washington maintained all along
there's not that many deaths you know
you don't know what you're talking about
so we can hand them those databases as
Philadelphia did with the schools
database we handed all of our data to
state of Washington prior to publication
said here's every you know all 27
hundred of them here's the circumstances
we know everything we can possibly know
tell us where we're wrong and they could
it and that's again the power of this
you chose to tell the story by telling
readers about your one of your main
character series is Angeline there are
two thousand deaths from methadone how
did you pick Angeline to represent those
two thousand why do we choose Angeline
Burrell you know is our signature
patient and every project you know we
call that sort of in the prior to the
signature the signature victim you know
you're looking for someone that that
embodies all the characteristics of your
readers if possible because that's who
we're writing for and that's who we want
to identify with the problem with pain
patients if anyone has encountered this
no families it's often a tragic
prolonged kind of story line and people
often blame pain patients for their own
problem because pain can't be measured
you can't see it in an x-ray so someone
sees you know a family member who says
that they're suffering from paying their
start taking drugs for it and then they
start into a cycle of depression and
maybe overeating and
of things and it goes on for years and
people start to blame the patient after
a while and this is what happened
Angeline Burrell but why we picked her
is because she could be you and that's
really the power of Angela Eber here's a
woman who has a committed relationship
she has a child she owns a home with her
companion she's works as a 911
dispatcher for the King County Sheriff's
Department so she's she's employed
everything you know she's living the
perfect you know middle-income lifestyle
and then she has an operation for a
gallbladder there's a surgical
complication and something gets nicked
in her stomach that was not accounted
for and she's left with is this
unbearable unaccountable pain the
doctors can't figure it out for two
years meanwhile the pain is just chewing
away her life she can't function on her
job her employees her fellow deputies
and everyone were giving her their sick
days to use this is how beloved she was
and how respected and has to paint eat
away her life she ended up losing her
home she was trying to find medical
treatment took two years to actually get
diagnosed with something yeah there's a
legitimate reason for your pain but by
then she had lost her home she's on
Medicaid she lost her insurance and
after she lost her private insurance she
was put on Medicaid and when she's put
on Medicaid she went to a clinic that
said you should go on methadone now
because that's the preferred drug two
days after she was upped when her
medication was upped on methadone two
days after she was given her methadone
dosage she died and the reason is
because methadone will kill you in the
first few days of youth that's why they
call it the silent death some people
react to it worse than others some
people are less tolerant and it stops
you from breathing angley and Burrell
was found sitting up in her bed palms
open she had just stopped breathing as
she was trying to get up out of bed
that's why we picked her that's why her
family was incredibly brave for coming
forward and telling you know what is
very painful story I'll ask our audience
now to ask their questions of Michael
yes hi my name is Annie Zack I kind of
have two questions the first is for
someone that might be embarking on a
health-related or medical related story
what resources or lessons have you
learned from covering that beat that you
find kind of most helpful and also
specific to this story
you do after you publish something of
this like magnitude investigative work
going forward from a watchdog angle how
do you plan to pursue it or how are you
pursuing to sort of check in and see how
regulations change in the future so the
first part of the question again was
restoring resources how you know what
I'd recommend quickly there is no topic
that you can pick in America where there
isn't someone in their basement who's
devoted their entire life to tracking it
and I try to find that person in the
basement you know who's got the the
moldy file cabinets and all the paper
but literally in health care there are
so many advocacy groups out there so
when I was doing a story about the
exploitation of the elderly for instance
you know I got together with the UM buds
men's office in state of Washington and
my might here's my tip technique for
finding victims does find an advocacy
group that deals with the subject ask
them to go through their all their email
that they've received for the last
couple years and find everyone on point
to your story have them email those
people on your behalf and tell them you
know would you like to talk to the
Seattle Times and in a certain
percentage those people going to email
back to the organization's I'd love to
talk to them and now I've got a list of
20 people who want to talk to me about
my core topic in the area and a specific
geographic location that I'm looking for
so it's a technique I've used in health
care a lot as far as again the second
part I'm trying to think what do you do
after it how do you follow up with this
I'm sorry is uh that it's hard when
you're a project report I don't know how
I'd be interested in the other answers
of this because you have to move on we
are planing follow-ups on methadone you
will check in a year later maybe two
years later to see whether deaths have
gone down and we'll try to do some some
annual story we've done out with some of
the other big projects that we've done
to it will go to this out of the room
yes hi Jenny Zhao I was wondering in
some of the stories in series you had
you know current patients who were sort
of you know discussing whether to use
you know the the oxycontin or or go with
method on a cheaper drug how did you get
access to you know current patients did
you have any pushback from health
privacy laws or issues like that
again we went through organizations you
know the dealt with pain and we asked
them to help us find patients who had
talked to us we in some cases we went to
our beat reporters at the paper and
asked him to look at their contacts
people who have messaged them over the
years so so one of the families were
used in a series that actually contacted
our health care reporter our beat
reporter Carol ostrom and asked them you
know ask Carol to do a story like a year
earlier and it wasn't something carol
was interested in are able to do at the
time but she'd saved the email she
passed it on to me and I contacted the
family became an OnPoint family for us
they say yes hi Henry kenzo I was
wondering when and why you decided to
publish your research in a series and
not just one single article especially
if you had one really strong character
was it from the beginning or was it
later on when you found this actually
affects a lot of people when we start a
project we like I said we kind of have
this criteria what makes a project and
we very quickly realized once we saw how
many methadone deaths were in a state of
Washington that we had an issue that
affected a lot of people the reason why
we chose to write it as a series is we
tried to cover the spectrum of issues
that go with the top sometimes doing
just one story if you try to pack it all
into one story becomes too confusing and
too many different diverse issues so the
first story was really convincing people
that there's this problem with methadone
and it's complex because there's a
subscrib all the second story was about
what about legitimate pain patients who
are losing access to the drugs and the
third story part of the series was let's
admit it there are some bad doctors out
there bad practitioners and their part
of the problem as well yes hi my name is
Stuart SIA my backgrounds in public
health and I was very impressed to see
your use of mapping software to look at
this issue it's actually a relatively
new trend in epidemiology to use GIS to
try to understand non-infectious
diseases like obesity for example I'm so
I'm wondering you know like I said it's
a relatively new thing in public health
what sort of drew you in that direction
to think home maybe we should start
looking at this geographically like was
there something that drew you in that
direction we've been using you know the
ArcGIS software for years you know for
with
stories and I think again it was about
three quarters into this project when we
realized what the role of income played
to the nature of our victims and that
came from looking to death certificates
kept seeing a number of deaths on the
south side of King County which tends to
be the lower income and I started
thinking wow I wonder you know what role
income does play whether there is some
type of relationship and so we started
looking than when we saw it as you said
it's too stark to ignore next question
piece I remember back in the 60s or 70s
there were such places as methadone
clinics where heroin addicts would show
up for a dose of methadone which was
supposed to wean them away from their
addiction how did methadone
metamorphosize into this Universal
painkiller maybe before you answer we'll
ask the last person in the cute also
asked a question and then we'll answer
both your questions in one go just to
save time I'm sorry hi my name is Maria
I just wanted to ask a general question
just said that your newspaper makes
money of investigative journalism how do
you do that how do you persuade your
chief editors that it is worthy that not
not worthy because it's worthy but it is
economically well the business model let
me answer the methadone clinic first
this was a hurdle with the story most
people know methadone as a drug used to
wean heroin addicts and so there was a
shift about 15 years ago where because
states were looking for cheap the
cheapest drugs that they could they
realized that methadones indications
also for use as pain it's always been a
pain drug but it wasn't embraced until
States started adopting these these kind
of prescription drug programs and so if
you look at the DEA charting methadone
usage not only washing them in every
state in the country has just
skyrocketed because it's become a
mainstream pain pill where oxycotton
costs you know say twelve dollars a dose
methadone cost a few pennies and that's
why it's become such a popular pain drug
as far as finances investigative
journalism trust me the paper doesn't
sell a single ad from a story that I do
they make no money throwing dust and
reporting excuse me they win put it
they win Pulitzers but Pulitzers don't
keep papers afloat and there's a lot of
testimony to that I think I think what
it does do those it brands us with our
our readers and our readers come to
expect this level of journalism in the
seattle times and it does i think
reflecting subscriptions i think it does
reflect in reader loyalty and
unfortunately i work for a publisher as
all of us obviously do that believe that
this stuff is important and no matter
what the cost no matter what the
prophets we're going to keep doing it
thank you